♪♪♪♪
-Hey, everybody.
Welcome to "Corrections"
for the week of
Monday, July 19th.
We have changed the title card
now to just say "Corrections."
I don't know why we ran
from that for so long,
but that is the safest way to be
error-free to start us off
I mentioned last week
that this was Emmy-nominated
this is an Emmy-nominated piece,
and I thanked the Academy,
and a lot of you said, "Hey,
the Academy is the Oscars.
Actually, I was right
in this case.
There is a Television Academy.
It's actually fully called
the Academy of Television
Arts & Sciences, but nobody --
scientists asked us to not say
the "sciences" anymore.
[ Laughter ]
Very few sciences.
I guess, like, probably on "CSI"
they have one.
I said -- I was talking abou
feeding chickens,
how a farmer would
feed chickens,
and I said they would feed the
chicken seed.
It's chicken feed.
You feed a chicken
chicken feed.
And I just wish there was a wa
to remember that.
[ Laughter ]
Like a mnemonic device
that I wouldn't make
that mistake again.
I referenced the film "Speed
and said that the bus
in that film
would explode if it went
under 55 miles per hour.
It was 50 miles per hour,
which makes sense
because 55 would be
unreasonable.
[ Laughter ]
You wouldn't be --
You would say,
"This movie is unbelievable.
So, my apologies
to Dennis Hopper's character
Howard Payne, who kept it
a reasonable 50 miles per hour
Do you know how much money
he wanted?
The ransom he had for the bus?
Guess, Shoemaker, how much money
Dennis Hopper's character wanted
in "Speed."
What?
-A million?
-$3.7 million.
I thought you'd think
it was more.
[ Laughter ]
Count on Shoemaker
and just get burned.
We talked about Bjork
and I mentioned that
I got it wrong
because the "J" is silent.
Everybody said it's not silent
it just sounds like a "Y."
And you are correct.
The "Y" in --
The "J" in Bjork
sounds like a "Y."
Which is helpful because if an
of you ever go to Reykjavik,
you will be known as "yackals.
[ Laughter ]
We talked about...
They're bringing back
the Microsoft Office assistant
Clippy as an emoji.
We told a joke about that.
One person reached out to sa
Clippy is just the nickname.
The character
is actually called Clippit
And I looked it up,
and that is true.
Though if you ever find yourself
taking the time to point
something like that out again,
I would advise you to...
clippit.
[ Laughter ]
Hey, this was not covered much
in the news this week.
This was sort of one of thos
buried headlines,
but Jeff Bezos went to space
[ Laughter ]
The way, like -- not r--
He went to space the way, like
someone in Long Island Cit
went to Manhattan.
[ Laughter ]
But we said that
Bezos looks like Data
from "Star Trek:
The Next Generation."
Bezos looks like Data
playing a sheriff
on the holodeck.
And someone reached out,
and I would like to read
what they wrote.
"Sorry to correct you,
but Star Trek's Data
never played a sheriff
on the holodeck.
And accident led to characters
in a holodeck program
taking on the appearance and
physical attributes of Data.
Even then, none of the
characters were the sheriff.
The image you are using
in this episode
is a character called
Eli Hollander,
who just looks like Data.
The sheriff in this
holodeck program was Worf.
Good effort, though."
And I went and checked,
and every part of what
this person said is true.
There's one -- There's one thing
that I feel is not true,
which is it starts,
"Sorry to correct you,"
and I don't believe
that person was sorry.
[ Laughter ]
Ooh!
I went day drinking
with Lorde this week.
This is a correction for
all of you, so brace yoursel
if you like dishing it out
but not taking it.
One thing we did at the en
of day drinking with Lorde
is we both tried to re-creat
the art of her album
"Melodrama."
Here's something we posted
online
'cause we wanted to let
everybody vote.
So, there's the actual painting.
There's my excellent attempt
and there's Lorde's bad attempt.
And yet I went to the poll
'cause we have a week-long poll,
and this is currently
where we're at.
Obviously, you see
Lorde is winning.
Now, I think I know
what happened here,
which is a lot of people are
huge fans of Lorde's music
which I am, too -- a giant fan
Yet some of you
are irrational fans
who then are elevating
her lesser talents,
like painting.
[ Laughter ]
And I also think what happened
is maybe a lot of Lorde fans
watched day drinking
who are not always necessarily
watching this show.
So now I'm counting...
I'm guessing
a lot of the Lorde fans
aren't here for "Corrections,"
so this is my chance
to talk to you guys
and say it's not too late.
We can't let this stand.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, we talked about
Lindsey Graham,
how Lindsey Graham is often very
servile and sort of obsequious
about Donald Trump, and I di
an impression of Lindsey Graha
saying that he hit
a 600-foot drive.
And a lot of you pointed out
well, that's not --
that's only like
a 200-yard drive.
That's not that impressive
And yes, that's true.
But I also think that
while you know that,
I don't think Trump knows that
And I think that if he hit
a 200-yard drive,
Lindsey Graham would think
"I'm gonna tell him
it's a 600-foot drive 'cause
he'll think that's better.
You know, and then he goes
back...
You know, the golf game's over
He's like --
[as Trump] "Lindsey,
tell 'em about the putt.
Tell 'em about the putt."
[Normal voice] And he's like -
[as Graham] "50 millimeters.
[ Laughter ]
[as Trump] "Gotta read a lot o
breaks at 50 millimeters."
[Normal voice] I mentioned
that...
Last week during "Corrections,
I mentioned that
the previous Monday was
the 20-year anniversary
of myself and Amy Poehler
auditioning for "SNL."
And a lot of you said
I should've said
Monday was the 20th anniversar
of Amy Poehler and I
auditioning for "SNL."
And then I asked Amy
what she thought,
and she said the correct way
would be to say Monday was
the 20th anniversary
of Amy Poehler
auditioning for "SNL"
and just leave me out of i
completely.
[ Laughter ]
We talked about shark teet
and how there's crystal meth
in the ocean now and...
[ Laughter ]
And that fish can get addicted
to crystal meth.
And as we all agreed,
sharks are fish.
And we showed a picture of
a great white with no teet
because, you know,
it's addicted to crystal meth.
And many of you pointed ou
the problem there
is sharks' teeth regenerate,
so even a shark on crystal met
that lost its teeth
would just -- the teeth woul
come back right away.
So, this is just,
if you know a shark who's trying
to tell you he's clean
and he's like, "Look."
[ Laughter ]
"If I was still on crystal
would I have these chompers?
Just know -- might be.
Somebody wrote last week
making a correction
and addressed it to
"the intern who Seth has rea
these comments."
I don't make an intern read --
Can you imagine
making another per--
That would be like
making someone watch
the videotape from "The Ring."
[ Laughter ]
Like, sure,
it'd make my life better,
but I would never
forgive myself.
Oh, we talked about how we had
this appendectomy graphic.
Let's put it up real quick
And people jumped in.
And we talked --
we addressed this last week,
that that's not where
an appendectomy incision
would be.
And then a bunch of you
pointed out,
"Also, why are you driving the
wrong way in the drive-through?"
[ Laughter ]
And so I took this down
to Graphics, you know,
'cause obviously now, you know
two mistakes in the same,
you know...
And I'm just laying into 'em
I'm like, "You!
You're making me look bad!
And then I realize
why they do it.
Like, they get off...
[ Laughter ]
...on getting yelled at.
'Cause I'm like,
"One, the incision's wrong
And two, you're going
the wrong way!"
And they're like,
"Ohh, were we bad?"
[ Laughter ]
So now we got to keep an eye
on these guys.
Like, "Ohh, did we mess up?"
[ Laughter ]
[ Chuckles ]
We used to do this thing
when we had everyone here
called five-dollar Fridays
which was we all wrote our nam
on a five-dollar bill,
we'd put it in one of thos
spinny lottery ball things -
if there's a word,
do let me know -- and...
[ Laughter ]
And we talked about it 'cause we
had Henry Winkler on this week
and when Henry Winkler was
back here in normal times,
he saw this, and the great
Henry Winkler said,
"Oh, can I play?"
And we said, "Sure."
And so he wrote his name on it
and sure enough,
of, you know, whatever,
the 50, 60 five-dollars,
Henry Winkler wins, which mean
he gets all the money.
But Henry Winkler's a great guy,
so he bought us all pizza.
Anyway, he's here this week.
We bring out the old machine
the thingy,
and we put Henry Winkler's
five dollars in,
and we decide to do it again
And Christine Arbulu,
our script supervisor, wins.
And I make a crack
that, you know,
this isn't gonna be a situatio
where we're all gonna get pizza,
'cause Christine
would never do that.
Anyway, this is, like, mor
an apology than a correction
'cause sure enough, today,
Christine got cookies
for everybody.
And I just wanted to make sure
that's clear,
and, you know, I also want
to point out
that that might not
have happened
if I hadn't publicly shamed her.
[ Laughter ]
So, you know, while everybod
is thanking Christine,
I think that, you know...
You know, on behalf of everyone,
thank you, Christine,
but also...
you're welcome.
[ Laughter ]
Um...last thing.
We had a little -- an ID.
I mocked up an ID because it i
20 years in the building.
And a couple things --
One, so, it was a picture of m
as a kid, and I held it up
and we took a close-up,
and a bunch of people said
"Uh, it said NBCUniversal
on that,
and that merger hadn't happene
in 2001."
And I'm like, okay.
Did not realize
you guys cared so much
about that kind of thing.
[ Chuckles ]
But the real feedback was,
a lot of you said,
"Dude, you need a manicure
Your fingers are disgusting.
-[ Laughing ] Geez!
-For real.
I talked about the prop budget
and people were like,
"You need a manicure budget.
And it's true--
I do chew my nails.
I didn't always.
I think I started around..
the first time
we did "Corrections."
[ Laughter ]
You know, 'cause I used to
you know --
I used to feel good about myself
and what I did.
And you remember --
The first time
Shoemaker walked in,
you know, the night I was doin
the first "Corrections."
And I was working on it
in my office and he comes in
he's like, "Oh! What's wit
the bloody hangnails?!"
[ Laughter ]
'Cause I was really
working on 'em.
I'm like, "I don't know
what to tell you, Shoemaker.
I said Legos
instead of Lego bricks
and the whole [bleep] world'
coming down on me!"
[ Laughter ]
But I do...
I do want to use this Olympi
hiatus that we're about to go on
to improve my situation,
so I'm gonna try
to stop biting my nails.
And, you know,
maybe in a couple weeks,
we'll take a close-up again,
maybe I'll feel, you know,
confident enough
to show you where we're at
And I think it's important
you know,
because I think, you know,
if this ends
with me holding that Emmy...
[ Laughter ]
...I want to have
beautiful hands.
I think that's about everythin
this week.
Do enjoy our time away,
and we'll see you
after the Olympics.